my name is John Fultz I do a bunch of
stuff with the with the Wolfram language
front-end and I am basically giving kind
of a survey talk of which I do these
most years there you go so I'm giving
kind of a survey talk of what we've been
working on the past year what you can
expect to see coming up soon and such
and I had a bit more difficulty with
this talk then with some of the other
talks and it took me a while to figure
out what the the problem was when I was
trying to come up with material for the
talk and I finally figured out one of
the problems is version 12 it's a big
round number and you expect sweeping
changes and big round numbers and there
are sweeping changes going on within the
front end but but a lot of them are are
only kind of partially peeking out
through version 12 and and they
represent you know there's their stuff
that's going on in there that's that's
definitely good stuff but they represent
part of a bigger picture and I don't
like to dig too deep into stuff that's
beyond the next release because you know
as a general principle I think it's not
useful to look too far ahead but but in
this case it helps me tell the story so
so I'm gonna talk about some stuff that
you're gonna see in version 12 and then
kind of place that in a framework as
some other stuff that we're doing so
let's go ahead and get started the first
and biggest thing platform supports
Stephen of course announced this the big
news is for the Mac people in the room
that we have a 64-bit Mac front-end so
yeah it was it was hard and I could tell
you war stories that's not what I'm
gonna do now what I'm gonna do now is I
will talk a little bit about about the
front I mean there's some stuff that's
pretty simple I mean in many ways it's
gonna look like what you're using now
except 64 bits and that's kind of the
intention but but there are a few things
to call out here and I'd like to go
ahead and do so so what are the
implications of moving from 32-bit to
64-bit well you know it's interesting
because one of the questions that I've
often gotten both with this project and
with other projects that we've done
where we've moved to 32-bit to 64-bit is
is it faster and that's a tough question
to answer in the abstract about you know
arbitrary software because because you
get some advantages from going to 64-bit
you know often you know you'll get wider
registers and more registers on the CPU
you know you may have you know more data
going over the bus you know that looks
good but then you're also throwing
around more memory a lot of times you
know inside inside the code it's you
know it's throwing around integers which
represent offsets and memory and your
offsets grew from you know grew by a
factor of two in their length and some
programs and ours is one of them do that
a lot and so you can see memory growth
and with memory growth you can end up
than blowing caches and that can lead to
a detriment in performance so I was a
bit surprised when I looked into what
was done for what we've done for the
cocoa 64-bit Fernan and discovered that
it seems to be faster across the board
it's very pleasant actually
and doing various sorts of operations
I saw result times for you know pushing
the front end to do either hard things
or repetitive things I saw result times
when compared to eleven point three the
eleven point three thirty two-bit front
end of you know I think the worst that I
saw was a result time is 75% of what
eleven three did and the best was forty
percent and so it depends on what you're
doing I in fact I kind of doubted this
at first and so then I went over to my
Windows machine and I tried eleven three
verses twelve and all the same
operations that I just done in my Mac
and the times were so close as to not be
you know sufficiently different so as
much as I'd like to say it was because
we did brilliant optimizations across
the board in version twelve it turns out
that that for whatever reason I could
speculate I don't know a hundred percent
for certain but you know it may have to
do with the implementation of of the you
know the operating system GUI calls in
in Mac OS or there may be some
virtualization effect going on when
you're thunking from 32 to 64 bit or
something I don't know but in any case
it's faster and it's noticeably faster I
mean most of the time the front end is
pretty responsive but you put a timer on
it you're definitely gonna see it so
that's that's great well one thing
that's a little less great well I mean
actually the what's great is that memory
exhaustion crashes are a thing of the
past and this is something when we get a
Mac OS specific bug report that may be
filed internally or externally some
decent fraction of them I don't know
maybe something like 5 percent of them
in the end turned out to be someone who
just
blew the limit of what their 32-bit
process could address and there wasn't
much that we could hope to do within 32
bits
except maybe try to reduce the amount of
memory that was being used and in fact
we didn't even necessarily have a
straight I forget whether mac OS is two
or three gigs but we didn't even have
you know you know a straight that amount
of memory to deal with because when
you're that limited you're dealing with
fragmentation as well which can which
can eat you alive so that's the thing in
the past and you know I'm not going to
go on record and say that to to the 40
bytes is enough for any computer in the
future but it should it should work for
a while oh I think but but one
disadvantage and has to be expected I
just talked about this is increased
memory usage and that's something that
you know if you're looking at an
activity monitor you'll notice that
pretty quickly so but overall it's
pretty good
the I'll just mentioned a couple of the
other issues so of course the principal
way that people notice this these days
is getting the not optimized warning
from your from your Mac OS and
unfortunately we could not make that
warning go completely away for version
12 and that doesn't have to do with
front-end it has to do with the fact
that Mac OS is very aggressive about
going through the entire app bundle
looking for 32-bit processes and and we
had one process it just lagged behind
the others in terms of what we were
developing we couldn't pull it out
because it has some critical stuff in it
but but we have a plan to deal with it
and I don't know I'm hoping that we'll
be able to deliver it well before
whatever the next major release is I'm
hoping we'll be able to deliver as part
of an incremental release after a very
tiny incremental release after version
12 so there were
some small interface changes the and
most of them you won't notice you know
but but we're moving towards being more
what one might expect from a native Mac
OS application the most surprising one I
will just call out which is oops which
is there we go there we go okay and this
is kind of small I'm sorry you may not
be able to see it very well but the
magnification widget moved and it is now
here in the upper right hand corner
instead of along the bottom and that's
that's because we're moving towards the
you know this Mac OS ideal of you know
borderless windows and the you don't
really have a scroll bar until it just
pops up out of nowhere that sort of
thing and that's so that's probably the
most surprising thing other things or
maybe noticeable but will generally be
subtle so that's good and so we're still
going to be adding stuff even after
version twelve and we have something
that works but there were a bit behind
in terms of catching up with some of the
Mac OS features that we couldn't do we
simply couldn't do until we moved to
64-bit land like for example supporting
gestures from your touchpad or being
able to respond properly to dark mode
messages which a lot of people had asked
been asking about as far as Mojave is
concerned and I'll mention by the way we
have you know we have good solutions for
something you know that looks like a
good dark mode but it's not something
right now that ties into the operating
system as operating system where I get
on our list of stuff to do
so that's what we have for version 12
but a lot of people have been asking
about high DPI supports and windows and
to a lesser extent Linux but especially
in Windows folks would like to see
something that is supports the modern a
scaling resolution that you see in in
Windows 10 and the good news is and I'm
not gonna say anything here that we're
not actually working on that I couldn't
you know if pressed pull out a
development version and show you not
going to do that this talk but you know
take my word for it I could pull out a
development version of Windows high DPI
support and show you and this is this is
there our next highest priority so I
would expect and it's it's a lot of work
it's more work than you might think but
it is definitely coming and as fast as
we can make it happen so we know that
people are very interested okay so
moving on from platforms Stephan talked
a little bit about notebook deployments
I'm just going to reiterate some of the
things he said go into a bit more detail
so the one of the big news is that is
that we're retiring free CDF and when I
say retire I don't mean deprecated you
know you still you know you have things
that were saved as free CDF everything
works just fine so it's it's not
deprecated in that sense but we're
retiring it because it's not going to be
necessary anymore
because the role that we had reserved
for free CDF is going to be reserved for
regular notebooks and and in that
context we're also looking at notebook
deployment because CDF was a lot about
deployment and so we're looking at
alternative stuff for deployment as well
and let me just go into a bit of detail
then on these points so what was free
CDF trying to accomplish well one thing
was it supported our web browser
plug in and it was difficult to have
kind of an arbitrary notebook with
arbitrary settings function well inside
of a web browser plugin well web browser
plugins died and so that's that's just
not an option anymore we pulled it from
the product and so I think we pulled it
in 11 3 I think finally after almost
every browser had pulled it out and
Safari I think was the last one to pull
it out just a few months ago
so the so that was one sort of issue
that we were dealing with and the and
then we were also I don't know I was
never a huge fan of this you know having
lots of deployment options but but we
had some concerns about what you can
open in player and having it be secure
ensured that you know you've you create
a file that you've made with our product
well those concerns you know in this
slight of basically going away so any
regular old notebook you want to open it
in player you will get exactly the same
functionality that you got before from
free CDF and there is still a thing
called CDF which is enterprise CDF you
have if you have an enterprise version
it gives you a few extra benefits and
we'll go into that andre has a talk
which I had on the it'll come up on a
next slide again andre has a talk
talking about that but it's still a
little more confusion than I would like
but we're simplifying I love simple
publishing a notebook so we now have a
menu item and it is really easy to use
you just have to be logged in and if you
if you're logged in then then it is just
so so easy and so if you want to let's
just make ourselves a notebook real
quick and I'm not even going to save
this because it's not even necessary to
save it the and sorry about the tiny
scaling here oh it's tiny around my
screen and up here but so we now have
published the cloud brings up dialog box
and the dialog box gives you a few
options you want to send it to anyone or
just a few people I don't think it's
really it's you know tends to be more
interesting for me if you show it to
everyone but whatever but but then
another set of options a set of options
up the top specify a name or
automatically assign a URL what's that
about
well the workflow here that I think
works best is if you're just doing one
off things you know you're just throwing
something out there once you don't
really care about it you're not going to
look at it again then just automatically
assign a name but if you're going to
throw something out there that you want
to update you know on a document that
maybe you make some edits to or updates
to and then post it again and again then
assign a name and then you can keep
publishing to the same name so in this
case I'm going to I don't care about the
name so I'm just and it's gonna tell me
what URL I went to so I'll copy that and
paste it in and there we go
easy peasy so so that is one way to you
know just make it really easy to be able
to to share your stuff with world and
then another now Windows users may
recognize this because we've had a send
to option in Windows for a while but it
used an older windows technology which
is kind of atrophied not as many people
use it you know especially if you're
using web mail it didn't really work for
you but but now we have an easy path it
doesn't you know you can configure it to
use your mail server if you want but not
necessary because if you just once again
if you just log into the cloud we
provided all
stuff for you and that is pretty much
the same thing here I can just take the
same notebook and oops and there we go
just take that same notebook and send to
and I'll just send it to myself and then
just go ahead and hit sin once again
super super simple I have done no
configuration on my computer I mean I do
use mail app but I didn't configure this
to use mail app it's just going through
the cloud all I did was log in and and
sure enough if we look at my email there
we go you know there's my little thing
that I sent and it nicely deals with
things like what if you send a large
notebook that's not going to work well
as an attachment it will just auto set
it up as the cloud document and then
send the link instead and most of the
time you don't even have to think about
it
so that's what we're doing now I forgot
to mention to Andres talk which was on
the previous slide there we go Andres
talk Friday 9:30 the what we're doing
later this kind of interesting not for
version 12 but coming I hope soon
thereafter is the ability to deploy
notebooks through Wolfram script if you
want a script that just you know that
includes a notebook or a series of
notebooks as you know as you know part
of a package but you want it in a single
file that's something that will have a
tool that you can basically you know
package up a whole series of things in a
single Wolfram script you know have it
be something they can be shared as a
single file but be launched as if you
have a little layout that includes you
know notebooks or whatever so
graphics I'm not gonna dwell too long on
this because you too Lou is giving a
talk at 10:30 tomorrow I just did want
to mention a few things though and I
just have a few minutes left so I'm
gonna speed through this a bit but you
get the idea first of all we have
polygons with holes and this is a
specification it's fairly
straightforward so we have a polygon in
this case I have just a standard
triangle and I'm cutting a square hole
into it and we're using this rural
notation here too I just have the of the
bitmap here just to make it clear that
there is an actual transparent hole in
here so you can see that so that's
fairly straightforward it works in 3d as
well and it really works with you know
with everything you want to do vertex
colors textures custom lighting whatever
you know face form whatever
fully-integrated
and it it does crazy stuff with you know
I'm showing simple convex polygons here
but but you want to want weird concave
self intersecting polygons everything
everything just works so also with
graphics we have a new faster method of
rendering transparency rendering
transparency is always an issue for us
because it's hard it's just
algorithmically hard there's no way
around that
but people ship new hardware and and
people write research papers and about I
don't know about every three years or so
you to comes up to me and says there's a
brand new method for doing transparency
can i implement it and so that's that's
what happened you know the last time it
was def peeling this time it's single
past that's sorting which actually u2
and James Lane who hasn't here worked on
that and that works right now it's only
implemented under OpenGL and
unfortunately only under modern OpenGL
turns out that Mac OS so OpenGL
not modern anymore which speaks to
what's coming we're implementing
direct3d for Windows for the for the
single pass step sorting and we're
implementing metal we're seeing the
writing on the wall
and OpenGL you know is not the future
that Apple wants it's painted but
because it's more work for us but there
we go we're working on metal and we've
made quite a bit of progress there also
we have some faster 2d stuff coming up
and then one more thing and then I have
a few smaller things I may have to skip
but one more thing that I just want to
mention we have the beginnings of full
Unicode supports and and it kind of
looks something like this
so now you can have your emojis I know
that this is probably the single most
important feature and now it's it's not
it's not a hundred percent baked for
version 12 but what is baked is you know
there's not gonna be any file corruption
there's not going to be any issue with
the computation or round-tripping but
there are but it's not fully integrated
into the editor yet so there's some
there's some glitchyness around editing
it copy and paste might be a bit of an
issue but there's a lot of stuff that
does work here I just wanted to point
out that this required a new form for
inserting arbitrary Unicode you may be
aware the you know the backslash : form
you know where you can do something like
that and that's apparently not a
character about that there we I don't
know what that is there we go
and so we now have a new form which is a
backslash pipe so backslash pipe 0 1 F 4
6 0 0 there we go or if you want to do
Sanskrit if I can remember it 0 1 2 fors
up type 0 1 2
for zero or something like one or some
yeah yeah so as a Sanskrit for I don't
know so I'm I'm kind of at a time but I
will just call out really quickly we've
done some interesting stuff with
presenter tools I'm using it right now
and some of the stuff that we did
benefits all dynamic interfaces you want
to find out more about that come talk to
me we're working on tableview it is not
finished yet but it is better in version
12 and it's ever been and it's really
close to being finished still
undocumented but please try it out if
you're interested
attached cells there's talk tomorrow
Jason Jason Abernathy is giving we were
building all kinds of our modern air
faces around it and WolframAlpha
notebooks that's the next talk so I'm
not going to spoil it so lots of good
stuff going on you have any questions
probably need to step out but thank you
very much